[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: This is Donnie
Vincent and he's a hunter.
And yes, those giant
antlers he's holding on to,
those came from an animal he
tracked, hunted, and killed.
For some of you, that may
be a tough thing to hear,
and this might be a
tough image to look that,
but the story of
why Donnie hunts
might make you look at this
picture in a new light.
DONNIE VINCENT: Hi, my
name is Donnie Vincent.
I reside in Hudson, Wisconsin.
And I'm a filmmaker,
storyteller, archer,
and a hunter.
This photo was taken on
the island of Newfoundland
in the Northeast region, near
a small town called Nambrok.
It was taken, basically, on
an unnamed lake in the middle
of a wilderness tundra region.
INTERVIEWER: Donnie
was on a trip
to hunt the woodland caribou,
but his expeditions are
a bit different than others.
Beside his camping gear
and his bow and arrows,
he brings along filmmakers
to document his travels.
DONNIE VINCENT: The photo
was taken by William Altman.
That kid has followed
me all over the world
in some of the most trying
situations you can imagine.
Alaska, Northwest Territories,
the Yukon Territories,
Patagonia region
of South America.
We've been surrounded
by packs of wolves,
charged by grizzly bears.
The goal is always
the same, just
to get fantastic images of
the wild places that we go
and to tell a fantastic story.
INTERVIEWER: And the
story this picture tells
is one of a man who had to fight
the elements, to become part
of nature, in order to
complete the task that took him
to this cold and remote place.
It's the story of an adventurer.
DONNIE VINCENT:
There's much reward
that comes along with hunting.
Everything from the places
that hunting takes me.
There's something
special about sitting
on the side of a mountain and
watching a pack of wolves hunt
a herd of caribou, and
watching animals participate
in their natural biology.
I want to chase adventure.
I have a need to go look.
I want to see what's
over the next ridge.
I have to see what's
INTERVIEWER: But it's
also a story of a nature
lover and a concerned citizen.
Donnie chose this
particular caribou bull
to kill with these
passions weighing on him.
DONNIE VINCENT: It's
important to kill an old bull,
because we want to be
hunters, but we have
to be conservationists first.
This was the right animal
to take out of the herd.
That this is an
animal that likely
isn't going to make the winter.
I'm not choosing to
be a hunter, this
is something that
lives in my soul.
This is something that I
inherited from my ancestors.
In fact, it's something that
I think lives in all of us,
and we all have this
piece of our brain
that wants us to go
back to the beginning
and wants to participate
in hunting and gathering.
But the world has set up this
infrastructure of grocery
stores and restaurants and
keeping everybody safe,
and for me, I want
to go screaming
in the other direction.
I want to get out
in the wilds more
and I want to have a
responsibility in going
through the process and know
exactly where my food has
come from.
INTERVIEWER: Donny
knows that what he does
is not for everyone, but that's
why he documents his hunts
and talks about his experiences.
DONNIE VINCENT: Hunting
is riddled with unknowns
and difficulties.
It's incredibly physical, the
weather is always challenging,
it's dangerous, but by and
large, the greatest difficulty
is taking an animal's life.
It's a really big decision
and something that comes
with tremendous responsibility.
It's never something
that we take lightly.
INTERVIEWER: Hey everyone,
if you liked this video,
be sure to check out more
of Donnie's adventures
on his YouTube channel, here.
DONNIE VINCENT: You
either have that,
that willingness to go look.
That willingness to
take one more step.
That willingness
to be uncertain.
Or you don't.
INTERVIEWER: And don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.